maybe a song
strum it for us
[Music]
nothing like the sound of flicked
strings am i right
welcome back to the chord or digital
podcast everybody we're glad you're here
i hope you're having a great day and wow
guys what's going on over there in the
studio i mean
i'm sorry we have a sound
came on so hard my bluetooth headphones
disconnected oh man
you're welcome
you're welcome nico's been disconnected
uh he'll be back soon but also alongside
nico we have jordan allen hey nick
laurent everybody
how are you guys doing
good yeah doing real wow vibes are highs
vibes are high like you guys have been
smoking the reefer or their high like
spirits are high spirits are high yeah
spirits are very high yeah dude
i think in general just uh there's a lot
going on
working on some fun projects got
batgirl oh my gosh do you do you feel
the like relief of having son of a
dungeon now nearly completed and punch
for punch as well being done
yes i feel that i feel no
absolutely because son of dungeon is
such a humongous undertaking
for everybody really and it's a multi
multi-month yeah yeah as i look directly
at the one person it's not
for everyone uh the one guy who doesn't
touch the show
yeah it's just a huge huge undertaking
and like now that we're in the visual
effects side of things nukes certainly
helped us
expedite a lot of the process which is
great but still it's like it's a slog
because we're talking what there's nine
hours yeah
and we we still have to do effects for
seven eight and nine
yeah and you're talking literally you
know right now we don't even have drafts
for vfx for after episode six yet legit
yeah and you're talking about like 50
shots roughly like you know 30 to 50 vfx
shots per episode and they're all
you know 10 seconds or more of green
screen photography and cg elements and
effect like
it stacks up it stacks up but yeah we're
moving quickly we're moving quick
yeah no you guys are moving quick and uh
batteries are dead oh no oh yeah he goes
headphones
why don't you run and go get a different
pair of bone phones
and then uh go buy some new bones niko
and once you're in the podcast i'm
so we put together a little effects team
of course jordan in addition to you
fenner uh and then also uh this girl
caitlyn and this guy martin out of
canada they've been awesome and you guys
have been doing everything in
nuke
yeah um
which is new for you
it is it's brand new and this has really
been awesome because it's essentially
like a training ground right i have this
theory that anytime you jump into a new
software
as much as you can watch tutorials and
enjoy that you will never get
significantly better without reps you
need need need reps and this has been
cool because it's been an astronomical
amount of reps you know it's like i want
to start working on biceps and you just
do curls every day all day for months
like you're going to get pregnant biceps
biceps you've all seen that photo of the
guy with like the he's the oil arms yeah
i don't i don't know how to do anything
except for this one comp but man am i
good at that one comp yeah dude and
having fenner there obviously is
insanely helpful because he's expediting
my learning process dramatically right
there's all these little tricks that he
does
that i've never thought of doing and
they're all genius
so you stick them all together and you
can get something really really good
looking uh really quick um and so that's
cool because that now applies to other
comp work that i do here um like you
know the trailer that we do the rated r
work that we do the render
challenges that we do so
it's been great for me
personally i was telling a guy this at
the gas station it's the discipline
this guy i was at the gas station it's
just like
just that
conversation
i i have i have conversations at the gas
station now anyway i was there this guy
was you know he's the only one working
he's working on the refrigerator like
he's in the back
fussing around with it trying to fix it
or whatever and i'm like what's up and
he's like oh just some manual labor and
i was like there's there's plenty of
that to go around and then he then we
started talking about work and then he
was like yeah man i'm just gonna i
i told my i told my wife as soon as we
move into the new house i'm every day
that i'm off i'm gonna be back in the
back house just streaming because i'm
gonna get my twitch game going and i was
like dude
you should yeah you know what the
difference the thing that separates the
men from the boys it's the discipline
and he was like oh all right all right i
got you
and then and then we parted ways
nice yeah yeah yeah you just
injected that discipline right into him
yeah well done well you know it's it's
the enthusiasm only gets you so far
right like very creatures
it's so true yeah yeah yeah and it's
it's when you hit that grind zone right
there's like a point in at least in my
experience in every software that
especially houdini that i've tried to
tackle where
your
desire to do it just wanes completely
like you feel helpless and useless and
you at a certain point yeah to your
point you have to switch the the knob
from
you know
encouraged and eager to do it to just
i'm gonna do it no matter what
even if i don't feel like it i'm gonna
put at least five minutes in and try to
get a rhythm and you do that until it
breaks again and you will have a break
again it will happen it always happens
um but yeah that you're totally right
that's what separates you know the
experts from the people who just get
their feet wet and then go back inside
i mean that's what i've been doing with
the um with the with the website and the
platform in general i mean i know i'm
not the one that's actually doing the
coding and the developing but it's also
been
for me it's been just okay we we had
this idea
four years ago five years ago we had
this idea what if we made our own
platform and it's just been a little bit
of that everyday
you know
and there's the days you don't want to
but then the days that you
the days that you do something new and
you get like the new tool and you can
and then you have all these parts come
together and oh man those are the days
that that i'm living for for sure
what's your exposure to that side of it
because i don't know too much about like
the back end of the website
quite a bit i mean scott and i catch up
at least once a week sometimes twice um
and it's just been a process of
i mean
his team has grown so much but i
remember when it was just him and me
and we're sitting there staring at figma
wireframes just going
okay home page yeah
home page okay um and then you know same
thing with app same thing with ios same
thing with android like
and just doing that and then eventually
you know we were able to bring on some
other people get some other people's
input get get people that are more
talented than us and just slowly
and now we're so we're so close to these
new features
that i've been so excited to
introduce
that i i'm like ah i just
like a couple more days you know but
it's like it was a couple more days a
couple of days ago yeah you know
and so i'm just i'm right i'm right at
the threshold of that
you know the satisfaction of having that
complete but not there yet so yeah
another few days yeah that's fair yeah
one chop at a time
yeah that's the way to do it exactly i
think it was uh i might be botching this
but i think it was kobe bryant who said
he was in an interview and he said
something about you know normally people
wake up at this hour and they go to the
gym at this hour and they put in this
many hours a day into basketball and
he's like but i aim to wake up earlier i
think it was like two hours earlier or
something and he's like every day that
i'm doing that i'm two hours better off
than i than my opponent and he says
after years and years and years you're
talking about thousands and thousands of
hours built in that the opponents don't
have
yeah and yeah you just put in a little
bit of day and it adds up so quick you
know that's the difference same thing
yeah that's like reading
you know yeah reading just get it you
read it
see most people hate reading most people
don't like reading but
i just make i just make sure i get in
those reps every week man yeah you know
it's like you're reading history
you're reading some really interesting
stuff because i just started dan
carlin's hardcore history welcome to
history yeah
i wish i could be in your shoes right
now and just
experience it for the first time you
couldn't get into king oh no it just
kind of waffled around for like five
hours this is what i told nick this is
what i talked about
what are you niko how dare you what
about xerxes yes this is gonna go
anywhere for like
too long because i told nick this is the
first my first exposure to this series
don't do that
i told nick i was like i lo like it's
exciting information but i don't see the
through line like there's so much in my
life episode two it's just called like
the whole history of that king of the
empire is the worst that's the through
line
podcast i've listened to of his well
that's exciting because i am quite
enjoying it it is a bit yeah all over
the place and i'm in and out i think
it's just because we have no context of
eastern history we're totally western
world war one start with world war ii
world war one listen to us
is far and away the best free one it's a
great one to start one with uh
also the
celtic holocaust i saw that amazing
yeah
is that okay yeah that's what i did but
it's like this isn't going anywhere
yeah
if you start with the celtic holocaust
and then and then buy the uh fall of the
roman republic
that one ties it all together and you
understand now you understand like
caesar's
purpose in history
interesting
and switch them around though oh you you
think switch them around well then you
have it in order you know oh switch one
yeah you have it in order it's a good
primer though i listened to it before i
did the roman republic because i knew
what it was leading to in that well i
guess actually
yeah i guess you could start with the
holocaust one either one yeah i guess
they do kind of like overlap a lot so
yeah the battle disregard that
disregarded so sick by the way the what
the final battle the celtic holocaust
yeah oh
like it's an episode of game of thrones
the final battle man history of like
he was doing like 10 000 soldiers
fighting like i don't know however many
like 100 000 celts one of my life goals
is to commit that battle to film
sometimes
well that's that's one thing that dan
was saying i admire that and we're
getting closer every day
yeah
technology to do that like yeah
my goal is just to type that as a prompt
[Laughter]
natural segue nico all right so hey this
is probably what the uh podcast is gonna
be about here in the title so hey guess
what you made that part in the podcast
um
so we got stable diffusion up and
running in the studio you're like what
stable what
are you talking about that was me that
was me like three days ago yeah going
what are you talking about
remember like uh
like three weeks ago
four weeks ago when we're like dolly two
is amazing and it totally changes the
game and can you guys imagine what it's
gonna be like in a couple of years when
people can just run prompts uncensored
whatever they want because jerry any
image they want and the cat's out of the
bag because dolly two is very locked
down no politics no violence no nudity
no nothing right
none of the good stuff so a solid like
three weeks passed and here we are and
we've achieved that other extent now
there's an ai that in my opinion makes
better images than dolly 2. wow
completely open source you can download
and run it and compute on any computer
assuming you have the hardware capable
of it and it's also
uncensored so you can rent you can just
make whatever you want oh god and uh
yeah so that that brave new world that
we were like talking about uh turns out
we're already there and it's a little
frightening how fast we went from dolly
to to dolly to being old news honestly
you and i yeah nico and i were having a
conversation earlier today and i was
talking about nerfs and nerf technology
and you know ren's been diving into that
stuff and
how fast that has gone from just being
on your computer via like python only
to within a couple of weeks
can you explain that quick for people
who think you're talking about nerf guns
oh yeah yeah fair fair so yeah nerfs i
don't know too much about them neural
something radiation you guys don't know
yet
come on guys it's been three weeks
neural radiance fields i could be wrong
about a lot of what i'm about to say but
i'm pretty sure this is how it works
it's essentially like a photo scan but
it doesn't bake in the light data and
it's not actually creating an an object
as we traditionally understand them in
3d it's creating like a fog volume
almost it's perspectives really it's
perspectives yeah so
10 perspectives or something and going
all right give me redraw it but redraw
perspective between this one and this
one yeah because it's like it looks like
this it's like live iterations from ai
of like understanding what the object
was based on your collection of images
so it's almost like perspective deep fix
yeah yeah totally perspective deep face
and it doesn't bake in the lighting
which is of course the biggest issue
with you know uh photo photo scans is
like the the baked in lighting and the
reflection issues and stuff you can't
put a scan glass you can't photo scan
mirrors you can't further scan
reflective chrome balls or anything like
that but yeah if you look up nerfs
n-e-r-f
it'll blow your mind it blew absolutely
blew my mind and the fact that they were
you know he was on the computer doing
some really cool stuff he showed up the
week or two after with it on his phone
and he's like oh yeah this just came out
and like the speed that this ai stuff is
moving blows my mind because when i just
wrap my head around what it is it's
already like three generations deeper
yeah in terms of what it can do so like
stable feet stable stable to usually
to be cool
so just a little background
uh
so stability ai
is kind of the company that led the
charge here on this release of this
image generator so it's based on
something called latent diffusion
so imagine so when you're training
machine learning when you're training
air
[Laughter]
all right so when you're training i mean
we use the ai very loosely the specific
stuff we're talking about here is
machine learning because ai can be
anything really machine learning is
special in that
you're going to
give the computer
something like a piece of data it's
going to run it through a black box of
just basically a random web of
connections that just change that number
to a different number based on which
neurons which connections it goes
through
it's going to spit it out that's all
that's really happening under the hood
it's like a statistical model right
and the thing is you want to alter those
numbers in a certain way and you're not
going to go in and affect what's in that
black box you're just going to tell the
computer to like you're going to say hey
here's my ideal
uh solution like here's the answer to
the question what's your answer to the
question and then if it does a good job
you're like good job black box keep
being more like that or if it does a bad
driver like bad job black box you need
to change what's going on inside of
there and so in other words the computer
just constantly rolls the dice until it
gets better at figuring something out
kind of like actual real-life evolution
also kind of how our brains work in a
certain way crazy um
so as long as you have what they call
the ground truth like your answer so to
speak
the computer can compare what it's spat
out to what it should have given you
and it can make a judgment call am i
doing a good job should i keep improving
in that direction or am i doing a bad
job do i need to basically pair those
parts off you know it's it's natural
selection the stuff that survives longer
gets to reproduce more the stuff that
survives less or whatever it doesn't get
to produce as much and so it gets pared
down
so
there's all these different ways you can
have computers figure things out you
know you can do recognizing handwriting
you can do recognizing speech things
like that in this case they went all
right let's take an image let's put some
noise on the image and let's have the
computer denoise the image let's just
take the image put grab literally just
pure mathematical random noise like you
get on your tv
if you have an old tv
and just you know literally opacity 10
to stick it on top
um
and there's actually a bunch of
denoising ai algorithms um and so it
goes okay and i'm going to try to
denoise it and it tries to remove the
noise and then you have like well i have
my image before i applied the noise how
well did you do computer did you get
pretty good did you get it or did you
kind of mess it up
and of course with practice the computer
gets really good at pulling noise back
out of an image and giving you an image
that looks as close to identical as the
original you gave it so sorry what what
is it understanding about like if it's a
bad black box
how does it know what to change in the
next iteration is it just randomly tries
randomly it just literally randomly
changes neurons inside the black box now
i'm way over simplifying but it is just
randomly changing stuff it goes did my
random changes give me a better or worse
result
and you're like and see measures like
well now that i look at your noise
removal you actually did a slightly
better result it's slightly better so
whatever you did there
keep that now as your baseline roll the
dice again and give me 500 variations
and that's what you mean about natural
selection yep yep and then go ahead and
take the best one again and then just
gives a bunch of variations takes the
best one again it just keeps doing that
until you end up with an algorithm that
you didn't have to code you just said
here's my problem here's a solution you
figure out how to get from a to b and
the computer's doing that which is great
so rather than you have to having to go
and like type the math to do noise
removal the ai is just making its own
code so to speak but it also means that
you can't actually see what's going on
in that black box like it's just a mess
of wires right it's like trying to
figure out what's going on our heads
anyways so you have this noise removal
right so cool it works on 10 noise take
your noise and make it 20
now remove the noise okay great take the
noise make it 30 now remove the noise
and so they kept doing this and the ai
is like getting better and better and
better at removing the noise and giving
you an image that matches the original
and then they went all right
here's an image that's a hundred percent
noise
remove it and the computer is like um
okay
and there is no image there was no image
to start out with it's just noise so
when the computer denoises it it invents
a picture
because it's guessing
what was under all that noise but it's
just pure mathematical noise so you just
end up with a picture and it's like it
looks like a real picture and you're
like wow that's great
and so they took that and they combined
that with clip which we've talked about
before which is the
uh basically it takes text and it judges
on a scale like zero to one so you can
have like a point five or point four
point three seven eight five six seven
two whatever it judges how well does the
text match the image so they took this
model which can generate pictures from
noise and they took this other model
which can
judge if a picture matches text and they
mush the two together and now you have
something called stable diffusion
dolly 2 actually works very very very
similarly it's also a diffusion model
aka it says the whole start with noise
and pull it out to an image
it's just a lot of what informs these
projects
is the models they have so they trained
stable diffusion on five billion
labeled pictures this is a data set you
can download it it's free to download
you can go online you can download this
data set of five
billion images all with labels how many
megabits
how many terabytes would you need to
hold all that fifty fifty two terabytes
of terabytes yeah
wow okay uh they're all formatted to
five twelve by five twelve and they
include basically there's a spreadsheet
that includes like the image includes
the text that was accompanying the image
includes the url where it came from oh
my gosh and that's it it's just a
billion urls yeah five billion urls five
billion images with text you can
download it
and see how small a five twelve by five
twelve images to think of 50 terabytes
of it is just so
billion is a lot that's a big number
we should do a video
roll through the whole folder
and it takes us like a year i want to
know everything that's in my data set
yeah i have five billion pictures here
let's pick one
let's bring in let's bring in an intern
and have him go to every url
where the image is pulled before he can
start work he or she can start work on a
project oh man that can be our like haze
prank for
hey i actually we miss numbered all
these files could you go through there's
one in particular we're looking for yes
they're 75 years old by the time they
actually get to finishing it
so why why five billion and not i mean
as crazy it sounds why not more why i
think
more is definitely a possibility i think
it's just a matter of building the data
sets takes time because you have to
verify it you have to go through and be
like okay i hope this looks good and
they actually just have a lot of ai
tools for doing all the verification and
judging if the you know was the text
that could fit which is actually what
they did for that data set is use clip
to judge if the text was fitting
appropriately
for those images so it's been like a
scrubbed
analyzed data set and cleaned up you
know this all just takes time so that's
why it's not 10 billion that's why it's
not 20 billion gotcha but you would get
better results if you had more or is
there not necessarily direct correlation
garbage in garbage out right so uh fair
okay if you can have 100 you can have
100 pictures and get good results
theoretically if it's good data that
matches what you're trying to do um
so in this case you know they got 5
billion images but what you kind of end
up with it's almost like google image
search except if you had somebody
vaguely have to remember the picture
then draw it for you
so you know if you go on a google image
search and you type a cat wearing a hat
you'll get real pictures of cats wearing
hats you go into stability diffusion you
type a cat wearing hat photograph
it's going to basically
look and think about its training it's
going to look at the model that i was
training on and be like oh what did cats
look like again what do hats look like
again do i have any do i remember any
cats wearing hats okay i think it looks
like this it's just just gonna basically
give you a blend
of that that knowledge as an as an image
um and once again i'm super
oversimplifying um but in other words
it can't really invent things it's never
seen before it can only like
mash up things you know uh you might be
able to say something that hasn't ever
been imagined before it's a match up of
things and you'll get something and you
will see images that are striking and
beautiful that you've never seen before
but you couldn't be like
you know
the next famous marvel superhero and
like it'll give you stuff that's kind of
based on its knowledge of marvel
superheroes but won't just give you a
cohesive well thought out brand new idea
right it's going to be a mashup it's
going to be a collage of all the other
stuff it learns which begs the question
a little bit like as we enter a future
here where a i can generate all this
stuff and everybody starts just using ai
for their stuff
what are they going to train ais on
like if no one's taking pictures anymore
if no one's making drawings if no one's
writing scripts
what are they going to use to train the
ai to write scripts and to draw pictures
okay i've thought about this not this
particular question but the idea of ai
as like in a way we're trying to
recreate the human mind but just that
can work millions of times faster
which is our natural desire it's like a
weird thing to want to recreate our
abilities inside a computer that can
move faster and technically if that was
our design wouldn't that then have this
inherent bias to want to create
something faster
yeah that would then have the same and
it would like iteratively and
exponentially get faster and faster and
faster
to where you know when the thing finally
pops up on our end it's like
you know millions of years worth of
research in a second the threat isn't
the ai that we create it's the aai that
the ai creates yeah and the aaai is what
i'm really worried about yeah if we can
be real for a second
the last words of human
[Laughter]
there's always the immediate desire to
go to the fear-mongering side of this
but if you look at human history we've
we've already been doing this for
thousands and our whole history totally
yeah airplanes airplanes perfect example
we looked up in the sky we saw birds we
were like how do those fly and we said
well let's just make something that kind
of looks like it and maybe that'll work
and then after a bunch of different
iterations of that we figured it out we
do that with all kinds of things a
camera lens we looked at the human eye
and and we said oh well what is what is
in the lens what is in our eyes
that allows us to capture light and
different environments and see and we
invented all the different parts of a
lens
to represent that
now it's important
the last frontier and now it's the brain
yeah yeah i'm excited for it but yeah i
mean
kind of to go back how fast these things
are moving is what's blowing my mind
it's way faster way faster than i
thought it was so fast yeah yeah and
it's all the reality is
logically it's only going to get faster
it's not going to slow down or plateau
until we're all dead until we're all
gone yeah go back to the fear
put it on my grave stuff your manga
right yeah i feel like that's my take my
place in this conversation yeah so
remember talking about things moving
really fast and all of us being freaked
out i'll show you something not just yet
i wait i'll wait for the right person
part of conversation
that's just me like it's gonna be like
oh god dang it i thought you're about to
say something else just came out that's
better than a stable diffusion it's on
its way
oh seriously that's what you're going to
say that's right let's do it right now
let's do it right now here watch this
video
all right i'll just explain what's
happening here
a tennis court it's a man playing tennis
and then they type in different words a
tennis court on a sandy beach
and now the ground is sand and
everything is completely normal wait no
it's on the moon and now the man is
running around on the moon
and it's this is the question i asked
this morning nico i said when is this
going to be 3d
oh i'm just skipping the they actually
have 3d coming too in a few months guys
i really like my job here please don't
get rid of me
[Laughter]
dude it has a shadow and everything
yeah that's incredible
wow yeah so we're all going to be out of
a job well no i take it back
so here's his fear-mongering now yeah
yeah here's the thing
i'm watching this light and magic
documentary uh it's about ilm it's on
disney it's awesome
it's like i feel like this documentary
was made for me it's all my heroes it's
like clearly made by i mean it's made by
lawrence kazdan and like ron howard and
stuff it's like these guys are it's a
labor of love right you can tell i i
have a feeling like no one's actually
watching this series on disney plus like
i mean compared to like you know
frozen i'm sure frozen one day frozen
now probably gets played more than the
lifetime of halloween sometimes this
documentary get played but a super
important piece of cinematic history
inspired a bunch of these directors so
they just poured passion into this and
it's an amazing documentary
but it gets to the point where
um they're doing jurassic park
and it's talking about how the model
shop is just they are on the top of
their game
uh phil tippett is like the world master
of stop-motion
nobody else is as good at this stuff
and then a couple guys like yo we should
do these dinosaurs in the computer and
everybody's like
you're like no seriously look just let
we're going to do it and so they spend
four months behind closed doors and they
come out and they have this one shot the
t-rex walking down a field and
everybody's just like oh my god this is
incredible and everybody in the model
shop is like
oh
crap there was our industry yeah and and
i can't remember who was saying it but
like one of the
managers that i learned was talking to
people in the model shop they're like
like how do you feel i think it's like
extinct and he's like yeah
you guys probably about two years
and sure enough like in about two years
most of the model shop was gone and
everybody was doing cg and a lot of
people in the model shop trained to do
cg right uh and made the jump over but
not everybody did
but i feel like we were at that point
right now for
art and entertainment
where
you know we had this era that was film
and models and paintings and then
computers came out and it was like oh my
gosh i can scan it into the computer i
can do everything i can do non-linear
editing in the computer i can do image
manipulation in the computer i can do 3d
models light simulation physics
simulations in the computer
and now i can generate all the pictures
i want but let's be real it's a pain in
the ass to do this it sucks it takes so
long to generate images that you could
otherwise if you had the money you go
out just film it instantly in real life
right
the ideal of visual effects isn't to use
blender the ideal visual effects is just
to type a few words and get your picture
finished right i don't want to sit in
blender for five days making a building
fall over i would ideally just type a
building falls over and then get a
perfect rendered image of it and then if
i need a tweaks thing i just tweak what
i write right yeah or whatever however i
interface with it ideally it's at
literally the speed of my consciousness
yeah that is that ideal
um and we are hitting a point right now
where this whole world of like computer
like image manipulation and bitmaps and
vectors and polygons like it's not going
to go away instantly or anything like
that but there's a new technology coming
out that's kind of like poking its head
around the same way that t-rex is poking
his head around the stop-motion
animation versus computer animation was
happening back in jurassic park and
it's a little scary it's a little crazy
i really don't think people understand
how big this is and like just how much
it's going to change everything not
necessarily in the worst and it's not
going to change everything but it's
going to change a lot for a lot of very
specific people yeah
and it's kind of how it spreads through
the industry too it's like yeah the
generating images is one thing but i
imagine in order to for example generate
a photo realistic building collapse
you know with smoke kick up and debris
directionable yeah
like yeah to actually be able to dial in
a specific look i
i don't even know how far away we'd be
whether it be like around the corner or
miles away but you were saying there was
something around the corner that can
make 3d models yeah so this diffusion
model can be applied to other things in
just pictures you can generate other
stuff with it yeah supposedly they're
going to do with 3d models very shortly
here but here's the thing it's like i've
always found this idea of like oh the
director gets to make the call and they
want you know we got we gotta build our
software here just so you know in case
the director doesn't like the way the
brick falls so we can change that and
i've always thought like what a
masturbatory like screw you director who
who cares when the brick frickin falls
like
like if you did an actual model and you
blew it up you get what you get like f
you get out of here like you are not
making a better movie by being like that
dust in the back let's actually make it
like uh five dust clouds that spike up
different like who cares that doesn't
have anything to do with anything
and i kind of feel like that's what's
gonna happen with ai a little bit here
it's like oh well the director can't
pick you know they can't say that they
actually want this car in the background
to be blue instead of red it's like who
gives a [ __ ]
i'm going to go ahead and just generate
my cars on my cool like city street
thing that i'm rendering and yeah if the
car's not perfect or you know if it's a
chevy in the background instead of a
ford who cares i'm going to go and do my
next scene while you guys sit there
modeling in 3d for the next five months
yes like and i'm gonna get my next thing
after that i'm gonna do my next thing
after that because the story matters at
the end of the day the story always
matters no one gives a crap about
anything else they just want to see the
story you literally what if this what if
the story's about a chevy though nico
does that really matter
i'm kidding well no
if the story was written by ai
then naturally ai would be able to
create the visual effects for it well i
think i mean jake you do bring up like
that is the crux of it obviously you do
need
a certain amount of being able to direct
it right it's just the hyper detail
direction that you hear a lot of visual
effects artists talk about
yeah i've always felt like that's taking
things a little too far well that's the
script yeah you just need an ai that can
deal with the biggest prompt of them all
yeah the film script the film script
yeah
this is a prompt
i write props yeah yeah
you know we're joking about this right
now but
that's gonna be it we're gonna be able
to do that yeah so in two weeks we'll
have another podcast we'll tell you guys
about the movie
like seriously the speed stuff is moving
like literally next year this time it's
going to be a little wacky
it's gonna be crazy
man but i'm not i'm not actually that
worried about it
because
the goal of all this is for people to
better express themselves right that's
really all it is right the world is not
a better place when you make it harder
for somebody to like make cool art right
right it's better when somebody can just
be like i have a cool idea about a story
about this wizard who rides a dragon and
the dragon is made out of legos you know
it's like well that's going to be
impossible to ever make a movie about
that but
if i can just do with ai and be done
with it because i'm just some guy that
has an idea and i don't want to sit
there and spend 10 years of my life
learning how to do this in cg
like heck yeah now suddenly everybody
gets to make art everybody gets to tell
stories
the thing is human beings are are
inherently
work we inherently make things harder
for ourselves not not that we do it out
of uh any sort of desire for for pain
but what we do
as old as time
we'll come up with a tool
and then we'll go oh that works really
well at doing that and now because we
have this tool we can do these three
other things
and now but then we run into a problem
with those three other things and then
we're like okay let's come up with these
three more tools and then we and then we
go okay now we can do nine things now we
can do 27 things that's that's just what
we do
so if if we have these and you can
prompt a
movie script
into a generating system and then have
that come up with something on the other
side we'll just come up with another
problem after that don't worry yeah
we're always raising the bar like yeah
i was arguing with somebody on reddit
who they're trying to be like spacex
hasn't done anything of value it's like
guys landing a rocket oh yeah it's a
pretty it's a pretty big technology not
pretty big let's be honest
that is a
an achievement of mankind straight up it
is achievement of mankind it's like
walking on the moon it's like launching
the first salad in his face being able
to land a rocket isn't an achievement of
mankind if you disagree with that you're
just you're not in reality get out of
your narrative
you haven't heard elon musk did a
twitter now he's bad but he didn't get
people are like so what they landed a
rocket why are they landing all of them
you know it's like we get so dialed in
to like our current settings where it's
like
yeah so what why why can't your rocket
land all the rockets land yeah why can't
your rocket also dance that same person
who was like spacex hasn't done anything
he's probably like [ __ ] their pants
when they first landed that rock
yeah probably i mean yeah it's totally
group thing i always think about like
phones too like
you know some people sit around not
everybody but some people sit around
they go like i just
i want the best i want the best phone
but it's so expensive why can't they
lower the price it's like
five years ago
the world's richest man couldn't even
have the phone that you have yeah like
it's so true it just didn't exist and
like and now you're like oh it's too
slow it's like your phone
literally is the pinnacle of technology
from like four years ago i can't 3d scan
any object i want into an image and then
use it on the side
this doesn't have lidar it's like so our
standards are always shifting so like ai
is going to come out and we're all going
to generate cool images somebody's like
yo why isn't why isn't your image 8k why
isn't your image moving why isn't you
know it's like
and that's just how people are like you
said we always make it harder for
ourselves we're always yeah we're
striving for the next thing it's not
actually a bad thing to always be
stressed out
that's inherent to our nature i mean
that's how we we're curious creatures
and as soon as we figure something out
we we want to apply it to the next
problem or come up with the next
creative implementation of it that's
just that's how we are i remember i was
using runway ml just last week
on a shot and i i had to click on three
frames to get a good nut okay and i was
not a happy camper and i caught myself i
was like what dude this would take me
hours what am i doing
dude like a year ago this is a by hand
operation
it's so funny yeah you're so right yeah
man
it's crazy
it's exciting though it's genuinely
exciting once the models are i mean i'm
gonna say this literally every time well
once this comes then i'm gonna be really
happy but when the model thing come out
i mean that's you know mid journey has a
new version of coming out which is using
stable diffusion under the hood also
it's on their own model using their own
data set that they've been using for mid
journey plus it has a new version of
clip
so it's going to be another step up so
you know i just spent a bunch of time i
just spent a bunch of time getting
stable diffusion and running on our
computers here locally at corridor
it's really not that hard surprisingly
um
i'm like i'm gonna put all this time
into it i'm gonna get it up and running
then people in the studio can use this
as a tool it's gonna be really great
we're gonna be able to do so much with
it i'm sure in two weeks my journey is
gonna come out with an update that just
like shames stable diffusion and we're
like well i guess let's all get on mid
journey again
we're gonna have to shout those 30 a
month yeah you know
it's funny though yeah there's like
there's different ways of looking at it
where it's like oh man now i gotta learn
this thing again instead of
this whole new door just opened to
possibility whereas like a generalist is
myself like i'm not an expert in any
particular thing but all these insane
advancements have made it so that i can
make like good quality stuff very
quickly by myself yeah you know what i
mean and that's awesome like everything
that comes out that's like the next
iteration or faster or smoother like i
can sit here and go i wasted all that
time learning how to do it this way well
no because i did that so in that moment
i could enjoy
making it but now it's even easier for
me and and it's just like i think it's
an approach like a mental approach to
to these things that are coming out
where it should be an exciting thing
this is a good thing for us like i think
it's a great thing a huge huge thing
because what it's going to allow us to
do is make narrative faster
and to tell
iterative stories faster yeah because
this is a tool at the end that's all it
is it's just a tool like it's not
replacing anybody it's just a tool cg
was just a tool and the model makers
could go train how to use the cg tools
and they can steal all the artistry all
the knowledge they have about the
details about how to build models and
you have to build in 3d still when
you're doing it on a computer it all
transfers over it's just a tool yeah so
it's the same thing like why do we learn
3d animation why do we learn after
effects why do we learn nuke it's like
it's because we're just trying to make
images
if if you can do it better and quicker
it's not about using nuke it's about
just getting your image quicker using
the tool for the job yeah i remember i
learned that after a long time of
forcing it in one program yeah and once
you realize you use the tool for the job
things get so much easier yep so much
easier yeah people but you don't want to
learn things sometimes you're like i
don't have to relearn this but it's
really never quite as hard as you think
it is yeah you just had to be able to
set aside like two weeks
and that's the thing is people never
have the two weeks yeah yeah that's fair
yeah
yeah and they're all kind of
you know like with anything when you get
to a certain threshold of knowledge
the people who are creating it or the
other programs that are similar
aren't that much different from the
other ones in terms of
there's basic functions that are going
to be applicable there's basic stylistic
techniques that are going to be
applicable
across all of them
it's very true yeah that's the way in
houdini because you're essentially
moving data it's the only program i've
ever used that works like that but once
you understand how this software is
interpreting data you realize that every
single program under the hood is doing
that but it's covering it from you to
make it more user friendly but when you
understand what it's looking for even
when you don't have access to all the
data directly it's so much easier to
find solutions
um and yeah it's like you know
throwing pain at a canvas like every
single software that you're doing as
long as it's in the same dome of visual
effects like there's going to be overlap
between softwares and eventually the
whole canvas will be hopefully be
painted if you know
you do that in all the different
softwares so i think it's just worth
mentioning like we've been talking about
this ai like
stable diffusion if you haven't seen it
if you have seen like mid journey or
dolly 2 it generates an image based on
your prompt but it's managing to do so
in a very cohesive way or if you type an
astronaut riding on a horse you're not
getting a horse with an astronaut head
you're not getting a horse and an
astronaut separate from each other
you're getting a horse with an astronaut
riding on that horse an astronaut has
one head has two arms two legs horses
four legs and one head and a tail like
it's cohesive
that cohesiveness has been so hard to
get in the images up to this point
and the other thing they did
so dolly tubes always feel like stock
footage because that's kind of what it
was trained on i mean we don't know for
sure but one of the things they did do
with stable diffusion is before they
trained it they rated the images on
their artistic
quality
so you have a program here that is smart
enough to be like
this is really just the data that i was
given going okay these images are pretty
these images aren't so when i generate
an image lean towards pretty and pretty
arbitrary but at the same time it's not
actually that arbitrary
uh you just have enough people rate it
you're like okay well these images are
objectively pretty because i re-rated it
that way so if you're going to generate
an image try to lean over there um but
yeah you just we're down in a situation
where you just get very
coherent good images not everyone's
perfect
but you can spit out a hundred of them
then find the one that looks right so
for those of you who haven't seen it you
know basically just imagine
being able to type in anything you want
without too much detail you can't get
super super specific keep it you know a
little general and then imagine seeing
that image in a style that you've
defined whether it's black and white you
know
35 millimeter film or it's an unreal
engine 5 screenshot
or a miyazaki frame right from a
miyazaki movie um
yeah it's pretty crazy stuff so
i have another
question another direction to go in here
i'm trying to remember what it was
i mean while you're while you're
thinking i will say for those of you out
there haven't seen it there's a video
uh online of someone taking their uv
from their photo scan and painting out
the roof of the building because they
didn't like it or didn't like capture it
well and they ran that through like this
ai image generation to iterate different
roof types
and then that spit out a uv map just
with the hole filled in with a new roof
type and they were able to throw it on
the model instantly like that use case
is genius and like there's so many use
cases like that that reminds me so that
would be photoshop up to this point
right up to this point if you want for
the whole thing you gotta use photoshop
like content to wear phil yeah so why
i'm not ringing i'm not ragging on adobe
here it's not there's not an
[Laughter]
why didn't adobe get here first why
isn't google here first why is there not
a major company that has this tool like
i'm generating
art at my fingertips from words why is
the number one media company adobe you
know or media software company
why why are they not the ones making
this tool right now how is the
multi-billion dollar company
just not the one that's making this
happen why is that is there not money in
it too much of a risk
but i mean if you think about facebook
or meta you know spending all that money
on
the metaverse yeah how much did they
lose how much did they leave
like that's a that's a humongous risk
but this this the reward of this seems
inherent of like oh you can generate
whatever image you want yeah 2.8 billion
2.8 billion when was that last year it's
too long this is priorities from this
week
look it's too late i think there's too
much of a hierarchy involved in those
bigger corporations and it's really hard
to push forward avant-garde new ideas
into a mainstream program that's used
all across the board
like
yeah why what like why why is dolly
two's images
like for the stop it thing it was like i
literally
highlighted the bop it and i said
stop it
perfectly
stop it
with the right colors the right
perspective i highlighted the face and i
was like make the kids screaming and it
was like
and now they're streaming yeah that
could be in photoshop yeah that in
photoshop years ago yeah but yeah i
don't necessarily know that it would be
that hard of a process to just because
they add plug-ins all the time yeah it
shouldn't be that hard of a process yeah
it should be the harder process for a
multi-billion dollar company to do yeah
i have a theory
my theory so a lot of this stuff is open
source not every single thing is open
source but a lot of it is open source in
fact
generally speaking
dolly 2
stable diffusion like even probably a
lot of most of mid journey
all the code is there for you to
download and do your thing the only
thing that's not always there for you
are the models the part where somebody
takes 4 000 gpus and 5 billion images
and then has the gpus crunch on those
images for the next you know two months
that part that file they don't always
share that file yeah you know but you
can make your own
you can gather gpus and you can make
your own models if you have the time for
it so
in a way like it's almost impossible to
close this it's almost impossible to put
a lid on that box and be like nobody
comes in except for the people i want
because
yeah sure maybe you have a nice model
that you trained but all the code all
the knowledge that you built your
algorithm on
everybody has that knowledge everybody
has that algorithm
and a lot of stuff is open source where
i don't know if you're necessarily
allowed to package it up but i have a
feeling that you're not allowed to just
grab a bunch of people's open source
software and then throw it behind a
monthly subscription like adobe would
you know but if you're providing the
platform we were talking about this with
dolly too yeah why they monetize and why
um stable diffusion doesn't so dolly 2
isn't monetizing you to use dolly 2.
dolly 2 is monetizing you to use their
website
uh the the source code for dolly too you
can go on github and download it you can
put it on your own computer they don't
have the model available they actually
have another model that's like a little
bit like trained on less parameters it's
like not quite as good you can download
that one
um
but you can go and get the code and you
can run on your own system it's just
it's just that when you use their
website and you have their gpus make an
image for you they're going to charge
you like a penny a picture to cover
their costs for you know running all the
electricity and the gpus and all that
kind of stuff all that infrastructure so
that's what they're charging you for but
you are under no obligation to pay them
when you use dollar 2 if you run it on
your own hardware and that's why stable
diffusion you're running it on your own
hardware mm-hmm but how are you
accessing the model so they just went
you know what here's the model
but that you don't need to use any of
their hardware to generate
system i will say this is a very there's
some maybe it's not perfectly analogous
but there's some analogy here to uh web
browsers
that it like google chrome
they don't
own the
search results that you know you're
getting when you use google chrome
but they did
create an efficient way to scour the
internet
sell your data oh yeah
sell those search results yeah
yeah um so
i don't know if that
that seems analogous here like somebody
could come along and package it in a
more efficient way you could but i don't
think you'd be allowed so i don't know
what the license is for because there's
so much open source stuff that's you
know it's standing on the shoulders of
giants right you have stable diffusion
but below that is a stack of like
a thousand other projects that are
incorporated into this project right you
need somebody's code that they wrote for
like image viewing you need clip you
need to use somebody else's code for
image manipulation you need to use
somebody else's code for
you know building your neural network
you use somebody else's code for your
uprising gan you know it's like you're
using other people's code to finally
make your code happen so i don't know
how far you can get with then going i'm
going to package all up and it's mine
and sell it you know it's like well no
you can't do that because you're
actually using that person's code you're
using that person's code using that
person's code and using that person's
code well if if it's open source i mean
this is one of those weird areas of law
yeah it's licenses right it's like weird
open source licenses well if it's truly
open source
and it's like hey do whatever you want
then you know if if there's some kind of
open source license license inherently
means it's not
totally this is all this is all open
source license in the sense that like
you can use it but you can't sell it you
can use it but you can't use it for harm
you can yeah take my code you can
repurpose it however you want but you're
not allowed to just take my code make it
a exe and sell it you know it's like
there's a lot of that yeah
yeah it's like the knowledge is free the
code is free do whatever you want but
you're not allowed to then just take my
code and put like a fancy graphical
interface on it and then sell it as a
program like that's my code still like
there is that stuff that's a lot of
that's in here but looking back at
google and facebook and adobe there's
another thing which is
how big do you think like an engineering
team is on google or adobe it's like 10
people
five people maybe 15 people like
you have a group of people that are
working on like one or two problems
in the open source world you have
thousands of people working on thousands
of problems and you can be the biggest
company in the world but
your team of 15 data scientists are just
not going to be able to keep up with
literally the rest of the world on the
internet doing things if you look at
style diffusion there's
thousands of contributions from so many
different people to get us to where we
are not a thousand people a thousand
people made uh stable diffusion as a
style diffusion earlier you know stable
diffusion was only made by a certain
team
but all the rest of the things that it's
standing on like the stable diffusion
team didn't make the data set the stable
diffusion team didn't make the gains the
stable diffusion team didn't make all
the neural network training plugins you
know like they just made the one last
little algorithm that sits on the very
top of all that you know all right are
you ready for the the big question the
hard-hitting question of all this then
nico yeah if you can't package
the software
and sell it
what gives you the right to package the
images generated and so that's okay i
was actually going to ask you that
question since you're you know since
you're a lawyer
because
the big thing that you see in all these
props now is that people put artists
names on them to get the style that
artists in them you know so it's like
you know fluffy puffy blue clouds in a
picturesque field
in the style of miyazaki and boop it
gives you an image that looks like a
miyazaki image
so at what point does miyazaki go like
hey you clearly used my images
with my name in your data set like there
are copyrighted images in that data set
there have to be yeah right you know
he's like
you know
how does that work how far can you get
with that like
oh so like
copywriting an image
in that you can't use my image to draw
and teach your ai yeah or even just
writing yeah like for the same time like
i can put this into data i can learn to
draw like miyazaki and draw an image
like miyazaki and he can't say anything
he can go right now
it would come down to like uh
the thing is the law is way behind on
this yeah so so but but it will evolve
to a point and the tools that the law
has currently would be to come to some
sort of
understanding of like substantially
basically this idea of substantially
created substantially influenced by
such that somebody would mistake it for
the work of the artist
it's that's a great point about the
lobby behind too because i just don't
know how they would catch up with how
fast it's moving like you can barely
stay up to date on what is possible yeah
let alone enacting always runs behind
human action but i somehow i feel like
that's on a curve now like it's gonna be
further and further behind total
speculation but you're right yeah right
like at one point are we just lost are
we just lawless you know what i mean
like
i mean this is pretty lawless stuff
right here already there like yeah he's
very lawlessness
like hearing congress grill you know
tech giants and using the wrong
terminology and like
it just you realize oh no we're we're in
the west here shoot yeah yeah
yeah i don't know which is maybe a
reminder of like
okay this is i'm i'm dipping my toe into
politics and i'm just gonna pull it
right back out so i apologize but it's
maybe a reminder that at the end of the
day it's like we have to be masters of
our own fate regardless you cannot wait
for daddy daddy daddy government daddy
whatever daddy boss ceo he cannot wait
for any daddies yeah or mommy's more
like grandma's mamas
or grandmas if we're talking about
politics you can't wait for them to tell
you if it's okay or wrong or you know
it's like you need to make that call but
you also need to be an upstanding person
who makes a good call don't just do a
shitty thing because well this is the
yeah that's the inherent crux of a
uh
of the republic that we're in it
requires it
jefferson they all acknowledge this it
you have to it only works if people are
moral
to one another
it doesn't work if people just do like
you were saying i'm going to do this
and and
who cares the consequences or
you know or i'm only going to do this
when somebody tells me it's okay both of
those things
until someone tells me it's not okay
yeah
yeah but yeah no that's that's a good
question um
but you know like
you gotta you gotta also have a certain
level of sophistication to be able to
get to the point that we're talking
about as well in order to know
understand how to apply these tools in a
manner that
would garner viewership of them in the
first place too
so
it's not like every
you know nefarious a-hole who wants to
just do bad is going to spend time
figuring this out because it's work and
you have to love it and it requires
constructive morality and discipline to
get to that point yep
also honestly like if you can generate
generate icky images in ai you might be
like whoa i mean let's look i'm just
going to say it let's say you're let's
say you're a pedophile and you want to
generate child porn i'm just look we're
all thinking about this
i'm just gonna dance around the issue
last time i'm just gonna say it this is
the thing that everybody thinks about
child porn right oh freak my headphones
turned off
they're shutting you down they're like
nope don't use that sound of context
please
okay but seriously
let's say you're a pedophile and you're
like oh my god i can use this to
generate child porn
let's say you do it it's going to happen
and you're like wow
there it is
and then you do it again you're like
okay there it is
and they're like okay that's it
now what
you just did it that's it like i mean
that's right
in jail
now now you get thrown in jail that's
what happens next i can't imagine they
would you
i just yeah
well because why i'm actually curious
well actually because technically
yeah well i guess we're going there
it doesn't matter if it's child porn or
anything else like should you go to jail
for just simply generating an image
because it's technically a victimless
crime right you can you go to jail for
tomorrow
i don't know isn't it a conglomeration
of other images though in a way so it is
kind of like thousands of victims kind
of just smushed together
that's a great point that's like you
can't you can't send somebody to jail
for drawing a picture right yeah yeah
but i don't know in the context though i
mean it's just a victim
yeah obviously you shouldn't [ __ ] do
it
but you can't send me a jail for drawing
a picture but i i guess to you to your
point this is one of those things where
then we need to make a decision as a
society yeah and say
well maybe we should make an exception
for that
i mean that is just a discussion worth
having but in the i mean in the
collection of images that it's sourcing
inside of this black box i mean there
shouldn't be any child naturally anyway
so
what you're generating is just a small
adult
which theoretically is actually what
would happen yeah i haven't obviously
have not tried to do this but um
but the point i was making is like we
talk about this big day
where like what happens once you can do
that it's like well cool what happens
three days later after that's happened
what happens once you can do it and then
you can generate your 5000 variations of
it you're like okay great i have 5000 ai
images it's like what happens a year
after that what happens two years after
that because we just thought that was a
big deal and we just blew through it and
now where are we right right we're
generating we're generating hundreds of
cool concept art images here in our
studio right now it's like wow i can do
so much with this and like in a few days
heck in a few weeks or months we'll be
like um
okay so we have like thousands of these
really cool images and now it's not a
big deal anymore and no one cares
you know and now we're moving on to the
next thing what do we do with this like
it's one of those weird things where
it's like you feel like you feel like
real life works in these like chapters
when in reality it's just a continuous
flow
and it flows past and just keeps flowing
totally yeah i don't know there are
consequences though to like anything
that manifests itself and if and if
you're talking about the
child porn thing then
you know
even though
you know you could say victimless crime
or whatever you whatever you want to say
about it the thing is is that
it it
if you're putting those out there
then now they're out there and and you
don't know you don't know who's on the
other side
and who's the next person who's going to
see that or the next person who's going
to get an idea because of that and all
is hired to bring it into the real world
right all of the manifestations that can
result from that it's
you know yeah yeah which i think is this
is where we talked about the whole like
law thing like
because the law doesn't lead like you
said jake it reacts yeah right so
we're quickly entering this this new
territory
we gotta figure this [ __ ] out yeah i
mean and it's not gonna be the same old
you can't just apply like you can't
really apply case slot you kind of like
caseload to it but at the same time it's
like
we're entering very new territory at the
same time and it's very much a while
what we need to start doing is we need
to start using ai to combat ai problems
that's really the only way to do this it
feels like it um
and and i don't know
you know i don't know who
certainly the government's not going to
be the most competent party to like step
in and go we'll come up with the
competent ai tools now what's a.i
[Laughter]
found how to regulate dolly one
[Laughter]
whether it's indecent imagery you know
uh
other things like messing with economics
you know things like that yeah the law
side of it there's all those potential
issues the the only in my opinion i
i don't know any other way to solve it
than to to come up with
other ai tools
that can identify and react to the
misuse
abuse and wrongdoing
of people through the tool
i don't know how i don't know what else
you do i mean for for basically entering
a point in society where you can get
raw generation
of your ideas
and it doesn't take anybody else to
generate it
we're going to enter a point where we
have to start talking about
what ideas
are we cool with and what ideas are we
not cool with and how do you react
accordingly outside just saying like
don't talk to me if i don't like your
idea right we have that right i mean we
kind of have that but it's like
in terms of law like a moral law code
right
kinda
child porn
laws yeah kinda yeah there's obviously
there's obviously laws against that i
mean there's a lot of ways we do that
though so for example you know
there's ways
first way people do it is if it's a
product and people don't like it people
don't buy it
that's the first thing um if if
sometimes we use sometimes we're able to
use the legal system
to come up with additional laws for
things like that um other times you know
we use mob justice
all kinds of different ways cancel
cancel this cancel that
um we we are doing that um
and that'll
i think inherently take its course uh
though there may be
but i think you're i think what you're
getting at nico correct me if i'm wrong
what you're getting at is the tools we
currently have may be falling short
i think it's more so that when you can
just
when you can do something like this and
such a paradigm shift and how you say
generate imagery
and it's gonna be more than imagery
right it's not just pictures soon it's
gonna be
3d models it's gonna be movies it could
be videos it's gonna be audio it's gonna
be books it's going to be video games
like
literally media right it's experiences
it's a simula it's the simulations of
our real life
it's like when you get to the point
where you don't have to hire technicians
and artists build it
and it becomes a resource-free instant
real-time just make your dreams a
reality at the snap of your fingers kind
of thing
it's gonna make us go back to the
drawing board a little bit and not not a
little bit a lot a bit and like when i
say the drawing board i mean like the
primal drawing board the very base of
everything you know it's not a law on
top of a stack of laws it's like okay we
gotta cut way back to the bottom now and
like start over
yeah i don't know like
like my op the optimism that i have for
humans
always exists of like we'll find a way
out
not to be doom and gloom because that's
not what i'm going for here but it you
know with with global warming
the way that it's going that's one issue
but this feels like something that can
get so far away from you that you just
you go you're just gonna find out when
you get there what the consequences are
yeah nobody has any idea and we don't
know how severe they are we don't know
how
consequently yeah positive or negative
like
it
is it's a wild ride i mean it's
something it's definitely gonna be a
hold on to your seats and see where it
goes it's like i know i'm bringing up
some pretty like far out there subjects
right now and it's like it's really just
for the thought experiment of it you
know it's like if you can generate any
image you want i mean that's look we're
human beings
it's gonna happen yeah like right
anything anything that we currently do
is gonna happen through ai tools no
doubt about it
yeah
yeah so i don't know it's it's messed up
and but also it's not all bad it's not
all good it's just it's going to shift
very fast but
i just remember like
we were watching all these uh ray uh
kurzweil videos back when we were
writing sync back in the day
he's talking about the singularity and
the singularity is the point
as at which change happens so rapidly
that all of our predictions
and planning and being around history
break apart because the singularity is a
reference to the black hole singularity
where laws of physics break apart
it wasn't like oh once we hit the
singularity things will be different
it's no once you hit the singularity you
can't make predictions anymore just like
you can't make predictions in physics
when you're in a singularity wow yeah i
think we have to complete chaos
you think we hit it i think we hit it i
think we hit it about 10 years ago
we just didn't even we weren't we're
just as we
it started with social media you know
this is the social media was the
beginning of the singularity
and it's just been so well sorry with
the phones really you know it started
with smartphones
and it's just been going faster and
faster
there's a story about this it's called
the tower of babel
um abel i always thought it was babel oh
yeah also known as
the artist
is this like is this like the babe tower
that's babylon that'll do humanity
[Laughter]
it refers to babylon
okay babylon yeah oh i didn't i guess i
never connected those dots yeah yeah the
tower of babel was in babylon who would
have thought yes yeah
yeah um so anyway yeah i mean we if you
remember what happened after that
there was a lot of people died that's
what happened afterwards tell us
actually tell us the story tell us the
story this is probably our good like
outro to the podcast but tell us the
actual story
well i believe the flood came after that
i thought the tower of babel my
understanding the tower of babel
mythology is that
um
they were trying to build a tower up to
the heavens
and god then made them all speak
different languages so they couldn't
understand each other hence uh speaking
like or babble um as you couldn't like
yeah it's gibberish
and that's that's
all babbling
no seriously as in like this is the
invention of this is like this is the
story the bible's origin story for
languages this is where languages came
from yeah god made everybody not be able
to communicate each other with each
other because they're building a tower
that's too big
and uh yeah they're getting close
i guess because they couldn't understand
each other it fell over or something
like that i don't actually know what
happened they just couldn't keep
building it
yeah they couldn't they couldn't
communicate with each other so they
couldn't continue to build it and that's
i mean look at
look at where we were it was like
we're building we're going to build a
perfect society it's 19 i mean this is
this is gonna this is gonna put me out
on the limb here i'm just making an
analogy okay this is right
but if you look at the analogy
we're building a perfect society to
heaven we're building a stairway to
heaven
everything's going to get better and
better and better
but where are we building away from
we're building away from the earth
our mother
this is all in the analogy we're b we
build away from the thing that created
us the thing that makes us who we are
and cares for us and keeps us
and we build away from it thinking that
we're going to a better place
and then god comes along and is like
actually no
you're wrong
and then we all fall down and then we
start over again
that's that's that's the analogy um and
i think a little bit of that
some of that analogy is applicable here
i'm just going to think all of it
yeah i think the whole thing
it's just how how fast are we going to
collapse
well i'm like not trying to be
pessimistic it's like going to happen
like no i mean nothing's missing but
it's going to happen it's like it's
actually i mean it's just i mean but you
look at the rise and fall of
civilization throughout the course of
human history and this is a common
exactly encyclical way that we do it you
know the roman empire lasted what like a
thousand years so yeah
the fall lasted another 500 yeah and and
like year 800 imagine like we our
country's been around for like a couple
hundred we're like yeah we're like like
250 and this is like 50. this epoch's
gonna last forever man
we're just gonna keep going up and up
until we're [ __ ] all just floating
and you know just in one consciousness
no yeah no dude
well you see it in the stock market too
the crashes right the the charts are
just reflections of emotion yeah at the
end of the day and that shows the human
like how humans kind of work right like
yeah you got this wicked ride everyone's
riding high and then just oh man we just
drop off the cliff it's like nothing
really changed from yesterday outside of
people's opinions yeah yeah and like
it's something i saw for the past
however many years in politics the the
massive divide that was created and it
starts to feel like on both sides it's
now a different language which is a
parallel to to
babel or whatever you want to say well
it's so easy you know yeah
it's so easy to live in your own reality
these days and you're on narrative yeah
because
everybody just absorbs the own the world
they want from the sources they want
which is driven by on the made up world
of the internet which is driven by the
news that you get is driven by ai yeah
yeah algorithm like totally there's a
great parallel joke let's be real let's
remember ai is just a tool people are
just doing it to themselves everybody
just fair fair everybody just wants what
they want they want the narratives they
want and they're going to consume the
stuff that look i'm i'm not going to go
out on the limb and say this i was on
instagram my feed popped up there's this
really jack dude and i was like dang
that dude's jacked so i click on it i'm
like oh shoot i go back to my feed for
three days it's only jag dudes
and i'm like what's going on man every
time i watch a new youtube channel every
time every time it's like yo i watched
one of those videos like i don't want to
see
every video that that person has ever
done now
for the rest of my life so the algorithm
is kind of to blame
a little bit here i'll take us out with
a little story here from a book called
steel beach um it's a great book great
sci-fi book if you like sci-fi you
should read it
so in steel beach mankind lives on the
moon specifically in the moon in tunnels
on the moon because obviously the
surface of the moon has no air
um something happened on earth and
people don't go back there
we're all on the moon now
um and society on the moon is run by the
central computer which is a just a
central moon computer
and
the computers has conversations with
everybody it's like siri right but
obviously like way more able to converse
because it's the future
and when for example there's like a
trial
the moon just has a conversation with
every single person about what they
think and then it masses that all
together and makes a decision in other
words it's just like ai now it gets a
sampling from every single person it
listens to all the conversations
amalgamates it all and then puts out a
result
so partway through this book
the moon kills half the people or the
computer kills half the people on the
moon and just goes and
main character's trying to figure out
why but basically it comes down to is if
the computer is talking to everybody all
the time
us as imperfect beings
have corrupted the computer to a point
where it has a existential crisis and it
goes like
yeah this is this is the bot tree this
is
nobody has purpose anymore nobody
struggles there's no reason for us to
live so bye boom it just kills millions
of baby
yep
so just an interesting thing to think
about
and how do we instill grace inside of
ourselves so that when the ai learns
from us which it's doing yep it's also
graceful that is true very well said
truth
very very truth very truth
okay jake play us a cool song play a
happy song jake yeah yeah
i think i'm gonna play stairway to
heaven right now
but sing it in different languages
[Music]
christian slow fade to
[Music]
white cut the terminator battle scene
flips
slowly fading across the screen
i mean we could generate some
you know apocalyptic imagery and that
was probably
[Music]
babies holding hands yeah praising the
son
[Music]
thanks for watching everybody beautiful